it's degrees now where some 5 000
migrants have moved into a new temporary
camp on the island of lesbos
they're among an estimated 13 000
migrants sleeping out in the open
since fires destroyed the island's moria
migrant camp where they'd been staying
police have been accompanying some of
them to the new camp with
migrants concerned they could remain
there for months
if not years
let's go straight to lesbos now and dw's
max zander
covering this story for us good day to
you max can you tell us about the police
operation
that's now moving people into the new
camp and about the response it's getting
yes brian well there has been a police
operation
ongoing ever since the start of the fire
in maurya
since the fire in moria about nine days
ago uh when police
first started blocking migrants who were
on their way to mitellini down this road
behind me
to get to the capital city here in lesbo
so they've been camping out ever since
now there has been a lot of police
deployed to this area
local police and riot police and it
seems that these efforts have been
ramped up over the last
two days since last morning when police
first started
moving hundreds of migrants
into the new facility that is behind me
right now there is long lines it looks
very different from the from the last
couple days long lines of people
who are um waiting to get processed who
are waiting to
move into the new camp karatepe and it
seems that
the authorities here are trying to get
the situation trying to get on top of
the situation again
and trying to get this over with opening
the street
for traffic and for locals to get access
to their businesses and
properties as soon as possible max
you've been out talking to
a lot of people we want to take a look
now at the report you sent us earlier
focusing on on some of the local
volunteers you've been talking with
it's two hours until lunchtime costas
polygonopolos and his team have to hurry
they are cooking for about 2 000 people
today outdoors
and with the most basic equipment not an
easy task
we often have difficulties with the high
winds and we need more helpers to come
here to join us
today hitaraki is on the menu greek
noodles with vegetables
the meals are provided by a volunteer
organization they set up this mobile
kitchen in the ruins of moria
just days after a fire obliterated
europe's largest refugee camp
this place used to be somebody's home
over here a gas bottle
next to a kitchen utensils people used
to cook here
next to it another home with water
bottles completely destroyed by the fire
maurya camp was home to 13 000 people
living here in cramped
unbearable conditions
is well aware of the extent of this
catastrophe he founded his organization
during the financial crisis
when he and many other people in greece
lost almost everything
he first began cooking for people on the
streets of athens and when the refugee
crisis hit the greek islands in 2015
they got involved here in lesbos since
then
their mission hasn't changed
we decided to come here firstly because
we have an urgent need for food
and secondly to calm the people down
take some of their anxiety away and show
them that we are with them
to show that not all people are fascist
or racist
and that we care for the people next to
us
volunteers and refugees cook and eat
together
trying to provide a sense of community
among people who are left
with nothing but one another
i was in the same situation before as
the others are in now
i understand that
most former camp residents have been
sleeping here
out in the open on the streets of lesbos
though security forces started to move
people to a new provisional camp
the majority of refugees and migrants
refused to go there
fearing conditions might soon become as
unbearable as they were
in moria
aid organizations are warning that the
situation among those displaced by the
fire continues to deteriorate
at a rapid pace they're basically
lacking the same things as they were
lacking already five years ago only
worse meaning that the excess of food is
even worse than before the access of
clean water is worse than before the
access of healthcare is even worse than
before
meaning that everything that we saw that
was bad before is worse now
during his time on the island costas
poligranopolos hasn't noticed
any improvements either he says it's
frustrating but he can only hope for
some positive changes
just like the people stuck here
if they don't have the hope they will
die all they have left is hope
to make a new beginning for themselves
and let their children live a better
life
finally lunch is ready and the head chef
doesn't miss out on the opportunity to
serve
this has been an intense experience for
him but today while dishing out meal
number 1500 he says
he's still on top of his game
his volunteers are determined to
continue for as long as needed
serving food with a share of solidarity
one spoon at a time
max hope is so important to all of this
as we saw in your report there
can you tell us about the new facility
which is meant to to give some of that
to the migrants what were some of
your impressions is it a realistic
alternative
to the one that burnt down
that's very difficult a very complex
question there brian um
us journalists we have very limited very
rare access to the new facilities i
myself was there a couple days ago for
the visit of eu council president xi
michelle and we were just driven quickly
through the new facilities and had a
little glimpse of what people what kind
of situation um
they or what kind of state the camp was
in back then it seemed like
the camp was being put in place in a
rush um
the ground just quickly prepared with
bulldozers and then
tents being constructed on top without
proper insulation
and without proper preparing it for
expected heavy rainfall and now starting
in fall and winter for example
also we've been talking to people who
are inside and they tell us that there
is still
a lack of access to facilities to
toilets to uh
medical attention even food distribution
and water distribution seems to be an
issue from from what we've heard
so probably not much better than than
maurya camp
also another important fact is that this
property where the camp is being
constructed on
was a former military base a shooting
range
so there's a lot of
most likely a lot of residue of
chemicals of uh
explosives of ammunition there so
definitely not a place where
um families or children or anyone um
would be
safe to live and have max
we have about 5 000 people according to
the latest reports that have moved
into that new facility 8 000 still have
not moved what what's going to happen to
the people the migrants who
say no we're not going in we're not
going into that new camp
what's going to happen with them
that's a very difficult question
refugees have been asking that them
themselves we've been asking us
the same question and i'm sure so have
the
authorities um i i'm sure there's not a
a a master plan in place but from what
we've seen so far
for the last 24 hours police security
forces
seem to have been stepping up their game
a lot more police has been deployed
water cannons right police have been
deployed so
it seems that they are really trying to
get control of the situation
whatever it takes max
thanks so much for for all your
reporting there from lesbos
you